[Music]
can tell you this one story
yeah what is it i said action i'm sorry
all right so in south australia there
was this
employee of a pizza restaurant
and you know how you can put mushrooms
on pizza you can what kind of mushrooms
should we should we put
mk dot farm slash joe for 10 percent off
you could get yourself a mushroom kit
and make your own mushrooms and you can
put it on a pizza i love
shiitake mushroom pizza sounds pretty
good i'm gonna ask would that be good on
pizza
i think so did you eat the mushrooms
that casey cooked
yes i did it was delicious thank you
very much he ate them raw in the car and
loved them
that's crazy i'm down yeah all right
anyway back to this thing
so a pizza restaurant employee lied
to contact tracing officials
and it led to a strict lockdown
across the entire state of that like
south
australia everyone who bought pizza i
hope um
and so it has a population of 1.7
million people and it began a six-day
lockdown
to fight this most recent outbreak of
coronavirus and it was linked
to this pizza restaurant and so
this one employee it says one of the
close contacts linked to the woodville
pizza bar deliberately misled our
contact racing team
their story didn't add up we pursued
them we
now know that they lied and so he had
said or he or she i don't know who it is
um they had said that they only visited
that pizza bar
place in adelaide for a short period of
time it was only once
when in fact they they ended up working
several shifts at that restaurant and so
that was the cause of this crazy
lockdown
and uh it was also another employee
another person with kovid was also
working
so corona people that were positive were
they just kept working and then
they were delivering corona in the pizza
yeah like they ended up like
spreading it too through the pizza where
they're coughing on the [ __ ]
pepperoni
let me tell you adelaide is i've always
said adelaide's a little
strange i've never been there adelaide
australia
was like the people were super nice but
it was a weird
vibe because like is it and i think it's
because now this is the only place i've
ever been to my whole life
where their time difference is in is a
half hour
oh wow yeah oh that's a lot of math and
i think no no it's just 30 i know kids
what do you mean half so instead of like
you know how
over here if it's like six it's nine in
new york it would be like it was like
6 30 in new york or something here's
adelaide that's the only
that's a that's a weird time zone yeah
you know joseph
what about the city that's directly
north of it on the other coast
it's not it's a different time zone i
don't know that's crazy
i always felt like that makes them a
little weird like
yeah that's the only reason yes well no
don't act weird no because i was out
there and and i remember thinking like
you know what there's there's something
like
a little different like everyone's super
sweet super nice but i'm like feels
different
they're 30 minutes ahead of you
something bro
but if you think about it that's the
only place he's been to his entire life
like that's not that
no it's the only half hour change diff
place up
it's jeez all it takes is a little bit
of change and it
can change things up right especially if
you think like you know maybe it has
something to do with like i don't know
maybe like the waves and the moon and
[ __ ]
like maybe it's [ __ ] everything dude
that's like uh you seen that movie
insomnia
by christopher nolan no oh yeah yeah al
pacino where he's in
i don't know iceland he couldn't sleep
anymore he can't sleep because it's
always daylight
at a certain time of the year i think
winter time yeah robin williams get
calling him
yep you know in alaska in the summer
the sun never goes down yeah
depends where you are would you want to
live there in adelaide
no alaska uh i like that you get checks
from the oil companies i think that's
sick
they have universal basic income yeah oh
yeah
they got bears too they have beautiful
it does
massive halibut massive crab legs
that's i don't know what else yeah
anything else massive can you throw
mushrooms there
i don't think so someone from alaska
buys a kit they can't do it
well indoors they could do grow it
indoors maybe candy oh yeah they could
grow it indoors does it ship to alaska
hawaii no don't ask me about alaska
[Laughter]
we don't ship to canada or hawaii but i
do remember the women in adelaide being
like like beautiful though remember
walking around being like oh
they're very attractive in adelaide dude
sweet you wouldn't notice that had some
[ __ ]
i gotta say some very hot women in
sweden couldn't believe it swedish
goldfish huh very attractive yes all
right
i want to go there so 1.7 million people
are they really mad at this one person
and what are they gonna do about them
yeah they're pissed because
like i said it made them go into a six
day lockdown but then they ended up
lifting the lockdown earlier
once they found out about this lie three
days earlier
and so um but the thing is they are
reporting that this person that lied
which by the way
it is a man a man of course
it usually is
trash that's right that's not what i
meant
but a 36 year old man from spain on a
temporary visa
it would be a spanish man and he was the
one we can't do that one that not that
one
why what because i use john never mind
just just
never mind later i don't know anyway
so yeah they're saying that he will not
be fined or
any nothing's going to happen for him
lying because there are no
no fines for people that lie to contact
tracing officers
it's the first of its kind so maybe they
will have that soon but it did
impact that whole state right so it said
like this
one quote says um is that the one where
you can't jog and then you can't you
also can't walk your dogs
i don't know how's australia doing with
the covenant wait let me tell you this
one quote
the selfish actions of this individual
have put our whole state in a very
difficult situation his actions have
affected businesses individuals family
groups and is completely and utterly
unacceptable
but he will not be charged or fined how
popping is this pizza place wait
uh they confirmed that he actually
spread kovid through the pizza spot
like how many people got infected
through the pizzas um
like a lot um i do remember reading that
but where were people did they ask the
real question though like was it worth
the corona yeah was it and they're like
yo this pizza's [ __ ] dumb
like you know what the pizza no but the
dipping sauce yes
26 yeah so that now they could advertise
yo
it's so good here people are willing to
get corona
it's [ __ ] sick mate this [ __ ]
pizza's [ __ ] sick mate it'll get you
sick mate
but it's [ __ ] sick mate is that the
only thing
they'd love to say
it's like we got a real aussie in here
no no
[Applause]
that's what they say when they catch it
[Applause]
why do they gotta say it with the r it's
so funny no no we don't no
no we don't no we don't
if you watch love island you've got to
watch low volume you can be dirt
[Laughter]
[Music]
are there australians on love island i
think so because the way that tim talks
it sounds identical how come us in
canadians just sound so
different from the other oh you wanna
hear a story
tell me a school no no i knew a guy i
knew a guy that um
he went to australia yeah and uh and
he went and people kept they they always
assumed he was
uh they were like are you from canada
and but he was american
are you from canada and he's like no why
does everyone keep asking from from
canada oh he's english
he says he's not like mayor no no he's
he's
like american another person you know
yeah and everyone kept asking him
why no like are you from canada and he's
like why does everyone keep asking if
i'm from canada and he said this is the
greatest country in the world
well what happened was the australians
learned that if they asked a canadian
are you american they would get offended
so this has to go the other way around
because it's safer you can't offend
americans
because if you'd be like canadian why
would you think that like we're just
being dumbfounded like huh
yeah but then you ask the canadians
they're they're like snow [ __ ]
canadians
do you think i have free healthcare [ __ ]
up
[Laughter]
if they call me canadian i'd just be
like i'd just be like
why would that be your first country
it's such a boring place yeah exactly
it's
it's the canadians that are getting
offended you know i would be like that
would be the first
thing that i think because like people
forget what canada is so then that means
that they were asking canadians are you
american because that's like obviously
the
the most that's their go-to the go-to
but then because they learned that that
was offensive
to canadians yeah that's cool so they're
being polite that's cool
but then aren't canadians the nicest
people in the world yeah offend them
that's why we no uh like that's why
they're saying for us if they're asking
us if we're canadian because they we
we're not gonna get offended if they're
thinking that we're canadian yeah it's
also a really long time ago so it's
irrelevant
canadians probably get their feelings
hurt
they get their feelings hurt they don't
get offended they just go
you think i'm american like you didn't
say please
yep they're very polite
i mean if they're not eating ketchup
chips american
american no true no i mean this is a
pizza plates or they call it a pizza bar
pizza pizza is it maybe
but yeah this is the place that is pizza
adelaide i can see it pizza no it's
probably pizza
pizza it doesn't look very delicious
it's okay photos okay
all right yeah now i want pizza they
also sell pasta
i haven't ate pizza in like ages and
beer and wine it's been a while
i haven't had real pizza in a minute
because i'm off cheese and [ __ ]
yeah i've been on get oh wait you do you
get it without cheese i do i order
have i told you guys this probably i
call i go to those places that provide
the vegan cheese option but then i get
the meat lovers with vegan cheese
oh i don't remember that cheese right
now it makes me break out i've been off
it for like a couple years
a couple years yeah that's a lot how do
you do the same foods without a cheese
uh well when i do send foods when i
would do some foods i'm always like all
right i gotta do it for the show but i
try to just you know take a bite get a
get a flavor and then not go crazy
you don't do the cheese at home so you
can basically not eat mexican food
i know we put cheese in everything
everything i just went to uh one of
these uh media taco spots with david
did you know
that place is delicious and they had
these fire it was like beef and cheese
and guacamole and like a crispy thing
and it was so
bomb and i was like i have to eat this
[ __ ] bro what was it what was it called
what was that uh exact thing called
sophos i forget it wasn't a sofa it was
maybe it was a sofa
i don't know but it was good i'll tell
you about i'll text you later now okay
thank you
which one it wasn't a watch maybe it was
a soap
was it a quesorito it's burrito
from taco bell authentic mexican crazy
authentico close
authentical you know i'm so mad like
taco bell took this
they they took this shredded chicken
burrito off their um menu bro mexican
pizza don't even talk to me the mexican
pizza and the cheddar why would they do
that
why would they do that the salad one why
would they do that i know
oh they're so stupid it's so good who's
their ceo right now
we should camp outside you know what
though do you like do you guys like the
taco bell at
uh that you make at home like they just
sell you the shells
and then the the powder no and then you
just get the ground beef
i kind of like that better no bro
because the
the beef it's not it's it's all it's i
like it
at home it's drier it tastes better have
you tried taking a [ __ ] after that
it doesn't just come right out of you
it's not the same at all
so different taco bell doesn't make me
[ __ ] like that yeah right
it really doesn't i have defended taco
bell on twitter so many times
because like whenever you're like oh
that's gonna give you the shits bro i'm
like you got a bitch-ass weekend yes
beautiful
no no i don't because i eat spicy hot
food all the time there's something
about taco bell that just
it just [ __ ] negates everything that
you've ever eaten it's like sloppy joey
yeah but i
know that you're not worthy they're like
you must get out of this [ __ ]
not worthy
[Music]